what is the ultimate nature of reality
this most first principled question
when we're born that we must ask
what is our relationship with God with
source with creation with the divine why
have we not made this the most important
question that society asks that we ask
ourselves that we ask each other and
that we collectively figure out what is
our relationship with God source
creation the divine what's the purpose
of the human experience is it to
maximize consciousness to maximize
meaning creativity experience love life
is it to have God's source creation the
divine creatively express itself
like a big symphony with different
instruments rhythms melodies and
harmonies each of us are a contributor
in that Symphony and the music we are
playing is what we are all collectively
experiencing another analogy for this is
a big painting with different paints
brushes strokes and sizes another one is
the stars with different sizes
brightnesses and planets in orbit
another is like cells with different DNA
purposes and expressions the similarity
between all of these is that we
co-create in harmony as divine beings
with unique gifts how do you bring your
gift forth
just like everyone has different
experiences with God source creation the
divine everyone also has a different
experiences with bringing their unique
gifts forth a couple principles one know
thyself to sincere self work clear our
channel so we can anchor the divine know
our ancestral lineage know our childhood
know our subconscious know our shadows
and be in control of our desires
[Music]
seeing life like a deck of cards every
card as a moment in time stacking from
your birth until your death some of
those cards had traumas on those cards
some of those cards have triggers on
those cards when we give that card love
it becomes on the other side our
greatest treasures we must heal if we
don't repair we repeat
love every moment of your past present
and future
surrender amor fati be in love with fate
and flow like water with the dow level
up your character gain experience points
gain accolades see synchronicities see
challenges see lessons and surround
yourself with other light spirit awake
love and divine people
all right what are some critical focus
is
well the United Nations sustainable
development goals are a critical focus
why are kids that are born into our
world not immediately doing
project-based learning around solving
the sustainable development goals what
could be more effective than education
being about solving society's most
pressing challenges alright this is
surface level let's get a little crazier
what is the source code of reality right
now we have quantum field theory and we
have general relativity
and for the last hundred years we've
been trying to find the theory of
everything
combining the strong the weak and the
electromagnetic forces with gravity
quantum mechanics is the reason why we
have computers smart phones internet gps
and MRI it's predicted that a
unification theory would produce
unprecedented advancements for
civilization creating new technologies
with understanding the source code of
our reality would solve the sustainable
development goals faster what are other
portals into our source code well what
you see here in the bottom right is the
C elegans which is a nematode worm what
you see in the top right is its cell
lineage which so shows every cell
division from the zygote to the adult
what you see in the left side is its
neuronal wiring diagram meaning the
whole genome is sequenced in the
connectome is mapped an organism that's
completely mapped provides an
unprecedented study of molecular and
developmental biology
the source code of the organism is a
portal a call to adventure that will
unlock tremendous meaning and
flourishing how about a completely
different portal this is la Sagrada
Familia in Barcelona Espana Antoni gaudí
combined nature with religion and
architecture like never before the
columns mirrored trees and branches it
teleports you off of Earth the
groundbreaking was 137 years ago in 1882
and it's in progress still unfinished
but this is transcendent it's
awe-inspiring artists can create portals
[Music]
do kids even know that they can focus on
understanding our source code what will
happen when we learn the source code one
theory is Ouroboros simplicity evolves
complexity which creates simplicity
evolving complexity simplicity evolves
complexity which can then house the next
simplicity which will then evolve
complexity again so if you take the
ranked linear hierarchy of complexity
from source to the Stars the atoms and
the stars to the evolution of the planet
to the evolution of single cell multi
cell organisms all the way up until
humans in the complexity of the human
brain making entire civilization on this
planet and you take that linear
hierarchy of evolution and you wrap it
around into a circle
the simplest part becomes embedded in
the most complex part and if we reject
linear causality and time and focus on
cyclical or AB or OC style of thinking
and feeling and connecting we can
experience how this is God's source
creation in the divine self actualize
[Music]
'uncle
for the source code we may be being
called to create more simplicity which
will evolve complexity and continue the
cycle but there are no guarantees
civilizations before us have collapsed
and we are in a culture war don't get
distracted by the culture war be
open-hearted yet discerning vigilant
focused exclusion plays a critical role
call security if the culture wars get
into your sense-making mechanism for
understanding the ultimate nature of
reality it's true we've also had a
history of incredible cooperation a
hundred plus billion humans built the
ubiquity in water food shelter
electricity transport computers internet
before us but billions died in wars and
genocides over land religion and
resources now we have exponential
technologies like biotech neuro tech AI
robotics and quantum computing being
democratized faster than ever we
incurred the twin nuclei problem in 1953
with unlocking the godlike power of the
atom and the cell we are ethically
morally and spiritually in kindergarten
with godlike technologies we are in a
wisdom race experiencing the perfect
amount of challenge for us to rise to
the occasion and prosper
our levels of individual and collective
wisdom need to rise up faster than our
desire for greed power and control we
are now gods but for the wisdom
it's time to diversify our asset of
consciousness across the cosmos before
either evolution or we ourselves snuff
us out like the anomaly we are the moon
Mars underground in orbit we have a
massive responsibility to spread this
light of consciousness and the next
cycles of creation but what about
traveling faster than the speed of light
what other aspects of our source code if
we unlocked could spread consciousness
faster staying focused on the ultimate
nature of reality is paramount there is
nothing more important than our
communion with the divine bringing our
gifts forth understanding our source
code in the next cycles of creation
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much for being here thank
you